Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is 2192. David P Here's a funny thing. We heard
about this at one point. I think it was actually
people around Trump who would say things like,
you know, Biden doesn't have the rally
crowds and he doesn't have the livestream
viewers and he doesn't have the Twitter
followers. So how could he possibly have
one? Here's a guy who called in very
angry with me who has a Twitter based
analysis of Biden versus Trump. Listen.
Speaker 6: Yes. My question to you is,
how many followers does Biden have on Twitter?
Speaker 1: Don't know.
Speaker 6: And how many followers that Trump have?
Speaker 2: I don't know.
Speaker 6: Maybe you should do your
research and see who has more. Four
times as many followers within a month or two.
Speaker 1: And why would I care about that?
Speaker 6: Then this idiot that's been
in the White House for two years. Okay.
You're the biggest loser on TV right now.
Speaker 1: Maybe I am, but that doesn't
have anything to do with who won in 2020.
Speaker 6: And I can argue every one of your
points that you have nothing
to back up your facts with.
Speaker 1: I encourage you
to call in any time, sir.
Speaker 6: You just say things like
their lecture was not read. This,
that and the other. Even though there's
proof to the other side, there's no proof.
Speaker 1: There's no proof nor proof.
Speaker 6: That it was, and that's not
a fact. So you cannot bring that up as a fact.
Speaker 1: This is the burden of proof, then.
They have not demonstrated with any evidence
that we should distrust the results. The
default is because elections have been happening
successfully in the United States for so long
that when you see that Biden won by 8 million
votes. Unless I have a reason to doubt that.
Why would I question it? They have to
present the evidence and they have not.
Speaker 6: Because that's your opinion.
To stop your own opinions. Because you're
a loser. And you're. You're killing our
country. You're killing our democracy.
Speaker 1: Yeah. January 6th. Rioters aren't the
ones killing democracy. Congressman Ralph Norman
texting. We need martial law. Misspelled, by the
way. They're not killing democracy. Me saying
I think Biden really won. I'm killing democracy.
Speaker 6: I think you should just
get off the air right away.
Speaker 1: Okay. Well, let's
do that right now. It's the end of the show, so I
will get off the air. We've got a great bonus show
for you today, though. We are going to talk about
the pushing of anti-Semitism to the forefront,
in particular by people like Kanye, Nick Fuentes.
And yes, Trump has has a role to play in that.
We're going to talk about that. NASA's Artemis,
this one is back from the moon with hopes to get
astronauts back there soon. We will talk about it.
And will we ever go to Mars or Nas? We will talk
about that as well. And yes, Sam Bankman-Fried,
the FTC's founder, has been arrested in the
Bahamas. A Bahamian arrest has taken place. We
will talk about everything that is going on. Make
sure you're signed up for the bonus show, folks.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you want to
make money. Everybody else that makes money
to fund themselves is bad. Pac-Man's a loser.
Speaker 1: That may be Alex, but the bonus
show continues. And no defamation suits with
$1,000,000,000 in in money awarded against
the bonus show. I'm very proud to say that.
You can sign up for a membership at join
Pacman dot com. You can use the coupon code
24 starts now to get a discount. I'll see
you on the bonus show. It's a great thing.